a Senate Republicans passed their
version of the tax cut bill which is
actually really a tax hike bill yes it
would give tons of money to the rich and
to corporations but it would increase
taxes in the long run for more than half
of all Americans as I told you last week
it would increase taxes in the long run
for millions of seniors as I told you
last week middle-class families earning
under seventy five thousand dollars a
year would see tax increases over the
long term graduate students would get
absolutely crushed and this would
increase the debt hugely but we have
Republicans voting in favor of it and
the version of the bill that senators
voted on was released just a few hours
before it was voted on as usual not
enough time to actually read it before
voting completely pathetic and the
entire thing has not yet become the law
this is some people have emailed me
saying now that this bill is the law
House Republicans voted to pass one
version Senate Republicans voted to pass
a different version and now and maybe as
early as this week the conference
committee will start and what they will
try to do is merge the two bills into
one
and ideally into one version that both
the House and Senate can agree on but
something really weird happened that
this is bizarre after the Senate passed
a version of the bill Trump said at some
fundraisers over the weekend that he
would consider a higher corporate tax
rate than the one that was passed in the
Senate bill which is weird I'm not
saying I disagree with that but Trump
has been talking about lowering the
corporate tax rate which would not be
good for hiring anyway by the way CEOs
big corporations have said no we're not
gonna hire more if you lower our tax
rate Trump has been campaigning on
lowering that and now he's saying he
might actually want a higher corporate
tax rate than the one that was passed by
Republicans in the Senate I don't even
want to concern myself with that that's
just Trump being Trump this is not a
good bill for most people that is what
I'm concerned with period if voters
understood things then we would all be
able to sit back and say don't worry if
Republicans get this thing passed
they'll get crushed in November in the
midterms and in 2020 as well but the
problem is that too many people are just
clueless about the details of the bill
they'll hear Trump promise the tax bill
and Republicans delivered a tax bill
they did it with no regard for what it
is even though this bill if it passes if
it becomes the law would be the exact
opposite of the populist paradise that
Donald Trump ran on there's this idea
that is out there as well for all of all
of you who believe that every senator
here is ultimately going to vote to pass
the conference version I mentioned this
last week there's this idea that there
are some more moderate Senate
Republicans Lisa Murkowski from Alaska
is one of the ones whose name is being
thrown about who voted for the Senate
version for now in order to be able to
say hey I was in favor of tax reform but
will ultimately vote against the
conferenced version so that they can
also say hey you know what I support tax
reform but in the end what the House and
Senate committees agreed upon would not
have been good that's interesting
political posturing in theater that is
sort of an aside to what's going on and
I'm curious whether we'll see that and
if she goes along with that then you
just need one more Senate Republican
right maybe Susan Bailey like absolutely
and that's not I mean I don't know if we
could say it's likely or unlikely but
there are moderately reasonable
Republicans in the Senate who I could
see not going along with whatever
totally abortive conference version
comes out of that I do hope that whether
this passes or not Democrats will do
everything that they can do to crush
Republicans with this in the midterms
make it clear that Republicans if they
pass this bill are taking hundreds of
billions of dollars away from families
and giving it to the rich and to
corporations period and the only path
forward the only solution is to vote
them out and that applies to a lot of
issues we talked about net neutrality
last week with attorney Andrew Torres
and we basically have to realize we
can't stop the repeal of net neutrality
we're beyond signing petitions were
beyond calling members of Congress
although I still encourage you to do it
Roy Moore campaign you just got a vote
right you've got a vote for the other
guy these tax cut proposals which are
actually tax hikes for more than half of
Americans in the long run at a certain
point the calls and the petitions aren't
going to do it you've got to vote these
people out yeah and I mean who's calling
for any of this known
net neutrality to be repealed yeah I
mean this tax bill usually you pass tax
reform when you know the economy's in
shambles right you think back to Reagan
and and you'd think it would maybe
stimulate the economy or if you believe
in those economics right yeah George V
Bush there was a surplus and maybe you
could figure you can put that money back
to the people's hands right there's no
reason for this they're just getting
away with murder it's funny because
Trump claims that the economy is just
doing so incredibly well well if if the
economy is doing so well and you've not
yet changed anything about how the
economy works and taxes are a big thing
the health insurance is a big thing
right now taxes and health insurance
which are two of them the major economic
components in the American economy
they're what President Obama left you so
if indeed the economy is doing so well
with the exact parameters that President
Obama left you why would you be trying
to make such major changes to some of
the fundamental aspects of the economy
that this is it's the vile
bottom-feeding stuff and speaking of
which Orrin Hatch senator Orrin Hatch
from Utah an example of there's the
morally corrupt deviance from common
decency Orrin Hatch during the Senate
debate about this bill the the topic of
chip came up children's health insurance
plan that costs about fourteen billion a
year and during the Senate debate about
this tax cut bill Orrin Hatch said we're
going to do chip there's no question
about it in my mind and it's got to be
done the right way
but the reason chips having trouble is
because we don't have money anymore and
to just add more and more spending and
more and more spending and you can look
at the rest of the bill for the more and
more spending I have a rough time
wanting to spend billions and billions
and trillions of dollars to help people
who won't help themselves won't lift a
finger and expect the federal government
to do everything how do we not have 14
billion dollars for children's health
insurance but we can add a trillion to
the debt to give tax cuts to the rich so
they can bank more cash and what is
orrin hatch talking about people who
won't help themselves we're talking
about children here kids
what is it that the kids aren't doing to
help themselves they don't have
full-time jobs what on
earth is he talking about this is the
mindset that actually explains the bill
the bit the poor kids minorities whoever
these are people who just want handouts
while big corporations and rich people
who have earned everything that they
have and more need to have their taxes
cut send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
today's program I am thrilled to say is
made possible in part by movement
watches I am wearing one of my movement
watches today
I despise holiday shopping because of
the lines and the driving and the
parking lots and the entire thing but I
also am not thrilled with the aspect of
giving and/or receiving gifts that I
don't really like or that the person
isn't going to really like that I'm
giving the gift to and a really great
gift idea is a movement watch and it can
eliminate the gift-giving anxiety and
you don't even have to get away from
your computer mobile phone or tablet to
do it and the gifts start at just $95
watches that if you went to a department
store you would see and you would
imagine that's got to be a 4 or $500
watch these start at $95 because
movement circumvents the retail markup
and the middleman by selling directly to
you online and you don't have to stand
in crazy holiday buying lines I love the
movement watch I've said it before I
have two different ones that I will wear
on different occasions people see it
people like it they say hey where did
you get that and I tell them where I got
it and the movement business model is
also an interesting one to me because
they started in a lot of ways similarly
to how the david pakman show started
really crowdfunding and using that to
build and grow a platform and they've
now sold something like a million
watches in a hundred and sixty different
countries you can get 15% off plus free
shipping and free returns if you go to
em VMT dot-com slash Pakman the watches
have great minimalist clean designs and
they make really great gifts save 15%
free shipping free returns at MVM t.com
forward
/pa que mas